hey guys yeah I am at Disneyland for
their diamond celebration and we are
about to make Dancing with the Stars
history
way better than a drumroll it's Alexa
Vega from Spy Kids and her husband
Carly's paying a junior from Big Time
Rush they'll be competing against each
other for that Mirrorball trophy that is
a way to make an announcement tonight I
mean pretty cool first married couple
ever officially on Dancing with the
Stars that's a big deal they're like oh
are you guys gonna get super competitive
I'm reeling from my husband I said I
support him I think he's great and you
wait to see him dancing what was it
about this show that made you guys want
to do it you know I think the
opportunity to work with my wife was
like kind of almost the number one cuz
we loved spending time together we're
almost two years married it's still
fresh it's going james maslow has done
Dancing with the Stars
buddy obviously from back in the day has
he given you any tips I sent him a
picture of my shoes and he just laughed
and he was like laughs and he was like
good luck man it's tough but was like
great sound tough is it we'll just ask
fellow contestant bindi Irwin she's in
LA hard at work and rehearsals for the
show